former NFL quarterback Colin Kaepernick
is not new to controversy as a player he
frequently used the NFL as a public
platform to protest what he called
police brutality and what he perceived
as America's ongoing oppression against
minorities in the country he famously
refused to stand for the national anthem
during games leading others in the field
to do the same look at the Sakshi war
with police officers depicted as pigs he
wore it in practice even donned a
t-shirt featuring Cuban dictator Fidel
Castro during a press conference ahead
of a game against the Miami Dolphins
Nike is now using Kaepernick to headline
their new ad campaign and the words you
see on your screen read quote believe in
something even if it means sacrificing
everything I'd like to take a moment to
remind Nike executives sacrificing
everything looks like it's not a
multi-millionaire social justice warrior
whose greatest feat of bravery kneeling
on a football field and wearing those
socks against our police officers
instead those who sacrifice everything
can be found on the ground in
Afghanistan as we speak US soldiers
fighting and dying to keep this country
safe fighting for a cause bigger than
themselves they can be found in the
bravery and the courage of men and women
that protect and serve police firemen
first responders that run towards danger
when we all run away and they can also
be found in graveyards all around the
world from Normandy to the Pacific from
Vietnam to Korea all across the United
States there are millions of men and
women who have really sacrificed
everything for strangers they didn't
even know so the world this country
could be a better safer freer place
there are plenty of heroes in this
country that Nike could feature but
Castro loving America let's see cop
hating X three year backup quarterback
is not one of them this weekend we sent
Tommy Lehren out to see what
Californians thought about Nikes new ad
take a look
[Music]
familiar with the gentleman by the name
of Colin Kaepernick Kaepernick
basketball player right Colin Kaepernick
is I have no idea who that is
donk I don't watch television I probably
wouldn't even watch this and I can just
announce they made Colin Kaepernick a
new face or they're just do it campaign
you think they made a good choice
yes because I think he legitly does
protest in a good way I think they made
a good choice just talk to me in about a
month when their starts go down never
respect what he does I think everybody
should have the choice whether they want
to stand up or not I personally don't
agree with that type of protest but if
Nike chooses him and they think he's the
best one then so be it
do you think that it would be smart for
businesses to stop with the politics to
my mind yes but but again it's like
where do you draw the line I said it
last season say it now for me I don't
support boycotts Saturday's my football
day I'm just sick and tired of it too
many men fought bled and died fighting
under that flag it should be one thing
that unites the whole country